welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for marvel's secret invasion on
disney plus yes i was at d23 in anaheim
earlier and i took a flight back to the
blue dungeon i'm very tired but that
doesn't mean i got to see this trailer
plus the additional scene with nick fury
and brody that preceded it exclusive
only to d23 attendees lucky me but since
i am on year four of my scroll search
i'm pumped for secret evasion finally an
mcu disney plush show that takes us up
seriously to an impression of agents of
shield and i love it so let's break down
all the details that you might have
missed in this trailer and try to figure
out who is a hidden scroll and why it's
me so the d23 footage opened with an
extended version of the scene with nick
fury and rhodey in the restaurant a
brief part of which that we see later in
the trailer how much you know about your
security detail what do you mean how
much do i know about him
but the extended version shows fury
suggesting conspiratorially that anyone
could be corrupted and rudy reveals that
he has actually known about the threat
of a squirrel infiltration for 15 years
15 years ago the pentagon brought rhodey
into a secret program when they first
suspected something was up so it sounds
like a lot of people know about the
scrolls or at least scroll spec them i'm
gonna stop forcing scroll into things
anyway according to the mcu timeline 15
years prior to this would be around the
year 2010 because probably around 2025
right now and 2010 would be around the
time of iron man 2 which of course is
when don cheadle first took over the
role of james rhodes from terrence
howard look it's me i'm here deal with
it let's move on but the fact that rudy
has known about the squirrels this whole
time makes him even more squirrel
suspicious in my eyes since he has long
topped my list of long-time well-known
mcu characters supposed normal humans
with government positions who might be
skrull imposters or at least have secret
scroll partners the way nick furious had
with talos how interesting would it be
if rhodey has had the same kind of
arrangement with a different scroll just
a different faction of scrolls and these
two guys were just unaware of each other
both having scroll friends but such as
the nature of spycraft you have to keep
such a tight circle that you don't even
know whose side you're on but i like the
idea of fury supporting one friendly
side of scrolls and roadie accidentally
supporting a less friendly faction of
scrolls because not all scrolls are
monolithic just like not all crees are
monolithic there's warring factions on
both sides this isn't humans versus
scrolls this is like human scrolls
versus human and scrolls also if 2010
was the year brody entered a government
squirrel program that could be on marvel
pays homage in a meta way to the terran
tower recasting as they've recently done
with edward norton and mark ruffalo and
she-hulk but the wide release trailer
opens with fury returning to earth in a
ship that drops in a beam of light his
form cast in a silhouette kind of like
how the humans look when they return to
earth in close encounters of third kind
but like the silhouettes of the aliens
who followed those humans fury's shadow
is initially amorphous and non-human
reflecting how the supposed humans of
this story might actually be alien
shapeshifters as to where fury has been
all this time the exclusive footage of
another title the marvels shown at d23
may finally answer that question a space
station that is called the saber which
seems to be based on the peak in the
comics the space station of sword at
least visually they look very similar
the name saber would be consistent with
the whole space organization of sword
sword saber now in that footage of the
marvels we see fury on the space station
with monica rambo space walking in the
space suit before she swaps places with
kamala khan and carol danvers i assume
this is the same space station that fury
was on with the squirrels in the
post-credits scene of spider-man apart
from home but then back on earth maria
hill shames nick fury for avoiding earth
and ignoring her calls but he says this
time is different i assume referring to
some rogue faction of scrolls invading
huge portions of humanity crossing too
many lines notice how fury no longer
bothers with the eye patch here allowing
that scar from goosaflerkin to breathe
but the nick fury at the end of the
trailer does bear the eye patch and at
that point he's trimmed his hobo beard
now to a hobo goatee i don't know maybe
losing the eye patch is one way the real
fury can distinguish himself from any
scroll imposter it could just be that
the precise way a flirkin scratches
one's eye leaves with such a unique scar
that makes it impossible to duplicate
for scrolls kind of like ditto and
pokemon with the faces i remember
detecting pikachu the movie with the
ditto face and oh that was the stuff of
nightmares ah every single time i record
one of these videos i gotta watch it
before it goes live to make sure
everything's perfect and that means i
gotta listen to it as well that can take
a while so i'm always on the lookout for
the most comfortable pair of earbuds
around but look no further because
raycon's everyday earbuds are the most
comfortable i have found oh yeah that's
the stuff it's like my ears are sitting
in a massage chair they got optimized
gel tips that make sure i get the
perfect fit every time and i don't have
to worry about them falling out raycon's
everyday earbuds also have an eight-hour
play time and a 32-hour battery life so
i never need to stop what i'm doing and
wait for them to charge it's also super
easy to switch between noise isolation
and awareness mode so i can choose
whether or not i want to hear my dog
barking at every single scroll it sees
when i'm out of the house and listening
to music i can use touch controls to
easily change the volume to skip a track
to answer a phone call whatever i need
to do it's no wonder that raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 50 thousand
five-star reviews to get yours click the
link in the description box or go to buy
raycon dot com new rockstars to get 15
off your recon purchase and thanks again
to raycon for sponsoring this episode i
just love that this whole trailer
swimming in classic espionage imagery
guns and envelopes ci agent everett ross
sneaking in an alley meaning this guy's
probably gonna make it out of wakana
forever just fine or maybe his squirrel
will everett ross also been pretty close
to the top of my list as possible
scrolls now we see someone with super
strength pulling a chain right off of a
locked door now scrolls at least in the
mcu are suggested to have somewhat
enhanced strength and speed agility all
that stuff but i don't think they're as
strong as like super soldier captain
america level olivia coleman is rumored
to be playing a character named
fallsworth maybe a uk counterpart to
nick fury a chief espionage leader if
that rumor is true she could also be
related to james montgomery fallsworth
the union jack of the helen commandos
and captain america the first avenger
could be his granddaughter great
granddaughter something like that we see
her examining rows of glowing corpses
and body bags on gurneys based on their
smooth heads i'm guessing these are
skrull corpses maybe this was a squirrel
hideout where various living scrolls
would hide all the bodies of any
squirrels that died so that human crime
scene investigators would come across
alien corpses all these years because
you know when squirrels die they revert
back to their squirrel form so whatever
skrull died they'd have to put that
scroll body somewhere and all that
glowing tech that surrounds them just
looks like alien tech ben mendelson as
taylor's grabs kingsley been a deer's
character as every other person in this
museum is a squirrel shape-shifting back
into his human appearance like which one
is the actual sexy bridgette star i like
how before the table behind kingsley
benedict shapeshifts we actually see a
few more king sleep in the deers over on
the left so yes this secret invasion
story is gonna include some squirrels
who are friendly to mankind and then the
squirrels who are hostile to mankind so
we're gonna see squirrel versus scroll
and probably also see human versus human
i like how this show's really blurring
the lines like that though still i'm
just super excited to see which major
avenger or avenger associate is going to
be revealed as having been a squirrel
this whole time and then which side of
the scroll race that they are on now
this museum by the way is london's
national portrait gallery one of my
favorite stops whenever i go to london
and currently is running an exhibit
called the faces of freedom depicting
various historical figures like winston
churchill over the far left there i just
love the shot composition here these
faces framed with the same repeated face
of kingsley benadir suggesting that
these girls might be kind of freedom
fighters in their own right giving them
a philosophical weight to their argument
but also it kind of hints that these
democratic leaders of human history and
maybe many historical leaders could have
also been scroll imposters really we're
rethinking our full history with this
show also it kind of foreshadows how the
u.s president might get assimilated by a
scroll we see various shots of
explosions in this trailer it looks like
a corner of london that's decorated to
look like a part of russia those are
russian flags and the russian letters
translate to national unity day we see
how olivia coleman's character enters a
meat locker where someone's being
interrogated or tortured and it's crazy
how she is directly handing them some
torture tools i'm guessing this is a
scroll resisting revealing themselves
but i'm assuming they're going to get
rescued later because we actually see
this meat locker with bullet holes in
the walls and commandos searing off the
door hinges then a couple dodc agents
open an elevator to find a case with
something in cold storage i guess some
kind of organic remains labeled ar4 dodc
has been playing bigger bigger roles
ever since spider-man no way home in ms
marvel and in she-hulk and my suspicions
were right that they are investigating
the scrolls as well they could be among
the anti-scroll agencies like the dodc
and olivia coleman's mi6 just the way
the dodc approached enhanced people in
ms marvel makes me think that they
wouldn't be too friendly about scrolls
we see amelia clark's character we're
assuming going to be the squirrel queen
varenki she enters this interesting
looking room with russian writing on the
door and inside a metal framework being
welded together actually another shot
later in the trailer shows fury entering
these same doors so i'm guessing
whatever this device is is going to be a
very very important piece of technology
maybe some kind of wmd that the
squirrels are trying to build on earth
to use against their rival race of the
creed we get one shot of a scroll in
this trailer this one's screaming in a
room surrounded by humans this is
different than any squirrel we've seen
there's far more purple splotches in its
green skin and then the final shot of
the trailer the presidential motorcade
gets fired on by an attack helicopter
that rocket levels the suv containing
the president those my friends are the
sexy black eyebrows of dermot mulroney
not dylan mcdermott not dory mcdilla not
derby about darmalor this is german
mulroney u.s president ritzen this is
the first time an american president has
been referenced in the mcu ever since
matthew ellis in iron man 3 i'm assuming
he's being attacked here so that a
scroll can take his place because in the
secret of asian comics presidential
figures like barack obama and john
mccain were implied to be scrolls ah
there's so much more to break down from
d23 it'll all be covered in the coming
days in due time anytime you can follow
me on tick tock instagram and twitter
avos subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you